and i said everything to my mom and she
said her opinion
and she said to me please don't talk to
trish i'm sorry i listened to my mom
bye girl natalie this is not
kindergarten
why okay she caught herself walking out
on mike's mom trish
after the rough thanksgiving they had at
her house she couldn't hook her
mom and without even knowing that trish
called her that for a fact
natalie made this exit as dramatic i
listen to my mom
why as it could be you always do this
natalie just come out here and speak
we'll get into her meltdown she did
nothing to you
so why are you acting like this in just
a few
i don't give plus brandon stands up to
his parents in a way that we've
never seen before i thought you really
understood
i'm tired of being treated like a child
of course this guy betty upset there you
go you said it
but surprisingly he didn't back down as
soon as we find
exactly what we want we're out of here
we're packing ourselves
out of here that's the way you're gonna
tell your mom
let's get into it
hey 90 day fans fam it's melisa
the moms the moms had it rough this
episode
i'm the big bad mommy let's go ahead and
get into natalie
who called her mom to tell on mike's mom
trish when mike was outside trish called
me a hooker
now just for some context last episode
natalie thought she heard trish call her
a hooker
but she says she didn't want to clarify
that at the time
because she didn't want to ruin
thanksgiving oh michael
oh mother world though oh
but now that the holiday is over and she
and mike are about to leave
natalie still hasn't brought up this
hooker situation
instead she is storming around the house
giving everyone the silent treatment
natalie i want you to pick a scarf
no i don't why
i talked to my mom i explained how we
beautifully spent
a celebration and i said everything to
my mom
and she said her opinion and she said to
me please don't
talk to trish a woman who insulted you
for no reason
is not supposed to talk to anyone
i'm sorry i listened to my mom bye
natalie really needs to go be an actress
that's what she wants to do she should
do it
no i don't she can channel all that
energy right there
on someone's stage or screen all mike's
mom really could say was
okay whatever is not just trish
calling me a hooker it's all the [ __ ]
down to me are you having a major
malfunction or what
natalie you're acting like a child right
now what's going on
natalie i don't know what i said or did
about would hurt your feelings
trish two days before me and michael got
married you called me
crazy and you said that you don't want
me to marry michael
when we arrived this time i don't
understand
these jokes you make towards me what
jokes
just say hooker i thought you called me
a hooker
i don't understand why she was so silent
about it
this is also proof that when you don't
deal with what's really bothering you
it starts messing with your mind
you start hearing things that people
didn't say conversations that aren't
offensive become offensive
it's just a mess my mom did not call
nelly a hooker
and by her not saying anything and
sitting there and pouting
uh it's not solving anything what did my
mom say for you to repeat
okay you always do this natalie just
come out here and speak
[Music]
natalie in this death stare at this
point
mike turns off his sweet frustrated
voice
i guarantee you it was a
misunderstanding and goes off
what was disrespectful answer the
question natalie went on to say that she
basically didn't like when trish told
her she should be an interpreter
what about what i want my dreams what
about i understand that but right now
with covet and everything you could
still do this
until it's time for you to go work on
the dreams
by the way trish only recommended the
job
because she felt like mike could use
some help i will choose the job i want
but why is my mom being disrespectful
for us it's not disrespectful to try to
help you
she did nothing to you so why are you
acting like this
i don't give about people who hate me
and
cancel my wedding and call me bad names
for no reason
i don't care i just know for sure i'm
not standing it
so bye see you never if the rumors are
true that mike and natalie are no longer
together
she did nothing to you so why are you
acting like this this had to be the
moment where ending the relationship
was decided at least mentally
you sit back there and pout all you want
ridiculous
get it done michael give her five
thousand dollars and send her back to
me brain disrespect
epitome of disrespectful your ooh he
said natalie is the epitome of
disrespectful
epitome of disrespectful your wow
you know mike don't play about his mom
too all gates upstairs
you coming
once they got to the airport natalie
kept her distance
literally gonna be a great flight home
oh boy she went straight through
security without mike
and didn't even say bye to trish i don't
feel like i own anything to trish
because
i took off my pin glasses
and the seriality i don't know what
reality natalie sees but speaking of
that
mike didn't want to accept his so what
time is it right now
come on claude and
you have to get on plane at what time uh
145 it loads
you want to go through nope
while this love story continues to
unwind
let's move on to brandon who was over
here trying to cut the umbilical cord
we'll do our best to just respect your
wishes and
what do you mean do your best last
episode his parents agreed to not
combining his dad's birthday party
with a wedding celebration for him and
julia we don't need anything like that
but they didn't end up sticking to their
word instead
they thought it would be cute to
surprise them
oh my gosh wow
[Music]
so we got to dad's birthday party and as
we enter the room
there's all this cool decorations um
you know some of it looks like it's for
a birthday party but you know some on
the other side of the room
look like it's for a wedding we have
half your dad for turning 70
and half for you guys just married
[Music]
um that is not cool and brandon went on
to make a point that i didn't even think
about
i mean this party doesn't seem like it
was for us
not for my dad it seemed like this party
was about her hmm
that makes sense why else would you
throw a party for someone who asked you
not to
that's the number one rule in party
planning don't do that
wig's got your special guests here yeah
look ron
and betty went as far as inviting
brandon and julia's wedding officiant to
the party
crying here well i like brian
she's so nice but why him here of course
all of this had julia pissed
it's so annoying it's an uncomfortable
position for anyone to be in
because then you're pressured to act
like you're actually happy
about the party and some people aren't
good actors
i don't want to look stupid in front of
my family they didn't have anything to
do with this so
brandon was willing to talk to his mom
about this later
and we have cake and we have cake but
then betty brought out a wedding cake
and she asked the wedding officiant
brian to get up and give a speech
so she basically did everything she said
she wouldn't do
i'm tired of being treated like a child
i talk to you for a minute yeah i just
feel
personally disrespected and hurt we
talked about this
i thought you really understood i didn't
think that you were that adamant about
it
we said no wedding stuff
really he would have never done that if
julia hadn't been there and i really
started to think that she's trying to
turn him against us
or against me betty is once again trying
to turn brandon into this child
who can't think for himself of course we
talk about it
later if she give more surprises i just
leave this party
yeah i'm sure julia's anger was part of
why he spoke up
but beyond that who wants to be treated
like their voice and opinions don't
matter
or aren't taken seriously well this is
just not
respect what we want and happy birthday
run
and we leave this party fine
julia loves to have brandon walk out on
people she had him walk out on his
friend melanie and her boyfriend at
dinner
which i will say was warranted but
walking out on this party
not so much that's very rude
although i understand why they're angry
i don't think it would have hurt them to
stay
or at least say bye to the guest but
i will tell you this i bet betty won't
do that again
back in my face like we did something
wrong because we didn't we
loved you and we wanted to do something
nice for you betty's tears didn't stop
brandon
from telling her that it's time for him
and julia to go
as soon as we find exactly what we want
we're out of here
we're packing ourselves out of here
that's the way you're going to tell your
mom
how about just saying we'd like to have
our own space and we want you to be part
of
our there you go you said it so you
can't go out and eat you can't go out
and take her out you can't do anything
because you have no money are you
kidding me hey ron
is that a real rod let's look we're
gonna do what we have okay
yeah you know what if you think you can
do it you go for it buddy you go for it
i hate when parents do that now brandon
you have to prove them wrong
okay if you want to be treated like a
man you have to act like a man
all right well next week it looks like
mike and natalie are back in sqwim
have your mom about gelato your ex-wife
my mom was very nice i have a name and
that's not a hooker
like there's no point in talking to it
because you just want to do what you
want to do
and you're going to step over everyone
in your path and it doesn't
matter when ally gets like this it's
just impossible to even have a
conversation
that's just not right all right 90 day
fans fam
make sure you stay updated on all the
latest news coming out the 90 day
universe
make sure you stick with et because we
are covering it all
i will see you next time
you